[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos sobre cómo van las
conversaciones sobre el pacto nuclear
entre eeuu e irán
previamente nos acompañó desde viena
austria rafael grossi director general
de la agencia internacional de la
energía atómica oiea y le preguntamos
desde la llegada de joe biden a la casa
blanca
vemos una suerte de tire y afloje entre
eeuu e irán el país norteamericano
quiere que teherán cumpla el pacto e
irán que eeuu le retire las sanciones le
preguntamos al señor gross y que se
vislumbra en esta relación a corto plazo
y esto nos respondió lo que vemos es una
serie de factores que están moviéndose
la situación es frágil y aún no hay una
claridad acerca del regreso o no de
ambas partes al cumplimiento estricto
del acuerdo
y se calcula que esto solo será posible
a partir del momento en que las
negociaciones entre las partes
comiencen además se reinicien y esto
todavía no ha sucedido
hay otros actores no solamente eeuu irán
en este tema por ejemplo la unión
europea qué papel juega en este bloque
comunitario
juega un doble papel
en el sentido que dos de sus miembros de
la unión europea antes eran tres porque
estaba el reino unido- y como usted sabe
a raíz del praxis no son más parte de
una europea son europeos pero no son más
partes de la unión europea
entonces en este pequeño grupo que
comprende a los eeuu a rusia y china- a
gran bretaña francia y alemania hay dos
parís y berlín alemania y francia que
son miembros de la unión europa pero
además la unión europea tiene un papel
de coordinación de todas estas
negociaciones sociales tuvo
históricamente cuando se negoció el
acuerdo de jaycee pib y lo tiene ahora a
través de el encargado de relaciones
exteriores de la unión el diplomático
español josep borrell que es el
encargado de este aspecto por lo tanto
la unión europea tiene a dos de sus más
importantes integrantes como partes del
acuerdo y juega a sí mismo como unión
europea un papel de coordinación en este
esfuerzo y finalmente como impacta este
tema en regiones como américa latina que
parecieran estar más distantes de estos
conflictos
es una excelente pregunta porque muchas
veces me ha sido formulada y creo yo que
lo que tenemos que entender es algo que
es importante me parece a mí como
latinoamericano
todos estos problemas son problemas que
hacen a la paz ya la seguridad
internacional de no existir un acuerdo o
de degradarse la situación de una manera
y de un modo tal que pudiese derivar y
ojalá que esto no ocurra por supuesto en
un conflicto armado las reverberaciones
de un conflicto armado en el oriente
medio
involucrando a los eeuu frente al cual
no se sabe qué posición tomarían las
otras potencias del consejo de seguridad
tendrían un impacto directo y concreto
con relación vivimos en un mundo
globalizado con relación a lo que pasa
en nuestros países y esto se verificaría
no solo en cuanto a las tensiones de
tipo militar o estratégico sino con
relación al precio de muchas materias
primas a la capacidad de nuestras
economías de volver a crecer o decrecer
en un marco de estabilidad económica y
de expansión económica global
en una forma muy sencilla vivimos en un
mundo
en el cual un conflicto de esta
naturaleza tendría implicancias y
consecuencias para todos nosotros demo
tal que no podemos pretender que porque
esto ocurre a 8.000 a 10.000 km de
nuestra américa latina'
esto no va a tener ninguna influencia en
nuestras costas porque no va a ser así
un agradecimiento de rafael grossi
director general de la agencia
internacional de la energía atómica oiea
en france 24 continuamos analizando los
temas importantes de la agenda
internacional y de las noticias de
actualidad siga con nosotros y nos vemos
más adelante en france 24 y en france 24
punto com buen día
[Música]